I had the great pleasure of being the founder of girls fights back and women
thinking education company after teaching lag self defense seminars to over 1
million people worldwide.
She's the old girls buy back in 2013 and since then she's been working as a
speaker,
an author and a communication strategist who helps people seek their purpose.
And
this fall,
last fall she spoke at Tedx Boulder was actually how our women act committee
found air and we were scouring the tonic folder site and all the different
videos and uh,
we were all blown away by your were really,
really fade out in the room today or she's going to talk to us today are why
once you talked to Todd,
I folder about how to connect with one another,
right?
Communicating authentically and that is one of the primary things we brought her
in her today.
She's about to do that.
I can kind of help us speak more authentically with that,
please help me welcome [inaudible].
Hello everyone.
I'm so happy to be here.
Are we projecting?
Is this good?
Okay.
All right.
You could magically make it happen.
We're Google,
right?
No,
this is not what you do here.
He magically make things happen.
But,
um,
my name is Aaron.
Wait,
I'm really excited to be here on International Women's Day is a big day,
a big deal for all of us.
I've spent a good amount of my career working in the women's and industry realm,
if you want to call it.
And it's a,
a place that I feel very at home at.
But I also feel like it's really inspired though.
I saw a few men in the room.
I think that's really important.
We gotta be super inclusive and this is so much bigger than women were.
Only half of the world.
There's another half.
And we got to bring the whole thing in.
And one of the things we're going to talk about today is how to seek our purpose
and speak our truth.
And one of the reasons that I feel so passionately about this topic is it's
because of women's issues.
If we don't know what's real inside of us and if we don't know how to show up
and communicate in a strong,
powerful and clear way that doesn't alienate and terrify people,
then we,
how can we ever expect to make progress?
So that's one of the reasons that I am here today is to share with you a tool
because I don't want to stand up here and talk and keynote the whole time.
I want to just give you a little bit of background and explain some concepts.
But then we're going to do an exercise where you all are going to learn how to
show up more authentically in your conversations.
This is beneficial when it comes to your personal life,
obviously,
but even in business as well.
So I'm going to show that to you today.
But first I wanted to give you a little background on things.
Um,
I actually wanted to kick off by sharing with you this really weird dream I had
recently.
We all have weird dreams.
I don't know if mine are weirder,
but I have this weird dream.
It was just a few weeks ago.
I feel the need to share it with you because it felt like one of those dreams,
it's so simple and so clear.
Yet you wake up in the morning,
you're like,
what was that?
And then later on you're like,
Duh.
It was like almost so spelled out that I couldn't get my head around it.
So here's the dream.
So I'm in this room and it's like a full white room and I am a glowing egg,
like a little ball.
That's all I am,
right?
And I look around in this,
out in the rest of this white room and there's a bunch of glowing eggs and
that's all we are.
And,
but I can tell even by looking at all these like little glowing marble looking
things,
we're all different now.
The only exit point from this weird white room is this amazing slide that you
would find at like a McDonald land sorta deal.
He's like crazy colors.
Woo.
You know,
like there's like a real party feel to it.
And so one by one,
each of these glowing little orbs would go up to the entry of the slide and
they,
a word would be thrown at them like freedom or abundance or love.
And they'd be like,
okay,
got it.
And they'd go,
they'd go
down,
and this went on forever.
And finally it was my turn and I got the word authentic and I was like,
wow.
Now the way that I remember
thinking,
wow,
this is going to be intense because to show up authentically can be a challenge.
And what I later learned about this dream was that all of us,
these little glowing orbs,
like maybe this is some weird explanation of what life is,
is that we come into these bodies and we get this one shot to show up in a
particular way,
to learn something,
to teach something to be a certain way.
And maybe it's as simple as just one word.
So mine being authentic.
I'm here today to talk to you just about that and I wanted to kick it off with a
quote and forgive me in advance if I trip.
It's probably a 100% likelihood.
Um,
uh,
no ballerina.
But I wanted to kick off with a quote from Carl Jung famous psychologist.
He said,
the privilege of a lifetime is to become who you truly are.
The privilege of a lifetime is to become who you truly are.
It really is a privilege.
And on this international women's Day,
I just want to take a quick moment to honor the fact that we have the privilege
to do the kind of introspection to show up authentically.
Because when you're in a war zone,
when you're wondering how you're going to feed your kids,
when you're living in extreme poverty or tear,
or even if you're in our world,
our paradigm,
and you're afraid to go to work,
or you're afraid to come home from work,
if there's something in your life that's not giving you the privilege to show up
authentically,
then how can you possibly expect to,
so we do have great privilege living in this time and in this place.
One of the things that I've noticed about Western women is that sometimes that
comes a little shame with that or guilt of like,
Ugh,
how could I even be upset about that meeting that just went horribly when I know
that someone's getting bombed halfway across the world?
Right?
I think it's our responsibility though.
It's our spill responsibility to own that privilege into rocket.
Because what I've learned about authenticity and when we show up,
it's like a ripple that creates this energetic force field around the world to
help other people show up for real as well.
So today let's do the work for the women who can't do the work themselves and
let's really affect the world by creating that ripple so that other people can
show up that way too.
So the privilege of a lifetime is to become who we truly are.
And we'll come back to that.
But I wanted to
give you a little background about me and how I got to this point.
Um,
I believe in connection.
I believe in connection of ourselves and ideas to other people.
And we,
when we can make those connections,
that's when we truly change the world.
A woman named Susan Pinker,
Data Tedx talk and her talk,
she's a psychologist.
Her talk was all about how connection is one of the number one things that can
lengthen our life.
Like if you want to know how to live to over a hundred it comes down to the
connections.
Now you might think,
oh,
it's about diet,
it's about exercise.
It's actually not.
Those are pretty low on the list.
The top two are social integration and close relationships.
And she did a whole Ted talk on this and it was amazing.
But I believe that it's even more than that.
It's not just having a close relationship,
it's having an authentic close relationship.
So how do we show up in that way?
So I learned how to do this back in 2001 I had just graduated from college.
I grew up in Chicago,
went to Eastern Illinois University and all I could think about being in that
little farm town was getting the heck out of there and move into the big apple.
So I moved to New York City,
no money in my pocket,
no job.
The whole deal.
The,
that makes,
it comes about this all the time,
right?
The girl from a farm town who goes to the big city that was made.
So I moved to New York and all I wanted to do was get a job in television
production.
I've always been a storyteller.
I was a speech communications major.
No one actually gives speeches for a living that do that.
Managers are so funny.
I already,
but um,
but I really wanted to tell stories and Hawaiian to tell real stories.
So I wanted to work in documentary production.
So I moved out there and for a year I was working on all sorts of documentaries
for history channel,
MSNBC,
really riveting stuff.
Now also the other side,
if anybody's ever worked in production,
it's not a very well paid field.
And so a lot of people have side hustles.
So one of my side hustles was working as an extra in reality television.
Just let that sink in for a minute.
Working as an extra of reality television being paid to make reality TV.
See more real and uh,
that was an interesting petri dish of,
of what is real and what is now real.
And what I learned is that there,
there was a lot of inauthenticity in our world.
I was kind of shocked the time,
it just how much there was.
But I remember through that experience thinking to myself,
we have got to show up more real and it's a choice.
How real do you want to be?
And we have that choice every single day.
So I bought back and forth between making documentaries during the daytime and
working as like,
this is okay,
let me just tell you exactly what I do.
So I worked with a show called eliminate.
It is as classy as it sounds,
if you haven't seen the late night reruns on Bravo.
So eliminate it's one person,
they go on a date with four people of the opposite sex and throughout the night
you get all these four people get eliminated until there's one person left and
then you like right off into the sunset together.
And usually in the midst of it,
there's fighting,
there's drunk in this,
there's belligerence.
It's,
it's insane.
Anyway,
it taught me a lot about that question of like how real do you want to be by
simply observing people who are showing up as so in authentic.
But the thing is about New York,
I had such a great time,
whether it was making,
making movies or making crappy TV,
I was just having a blast in this experience.
So I was doing that for about a year when I got a phone call that one of my best
friends from back when I went to college at Eastern Illinois University named
Shannon Mcnamara had been murdered while fighting off an attacker in her
apartment.
This was one of those game changing moments were kind of reminds me almost of
the matrix.
You know,
when neos given the choice between the two pills and he has the choice to like
go to the real world,
which is kind of darker and gritty and intense and scary and uncertain or live
in the program,
which is light and orderly and very sensical and predictable and safe.
And in that moment of getting the news that Shannon had been killed,
I was like,
wow.
Like,
there's this whole underbelly of the world.
And I mean,
I'm almost embarrassed they'd like to that point in my life,
I really hadn't gone through anything bad.
I really was one of those people that had had kind of a sheltered existence.
And so I remember getting that news and just the whole world's shifting and
seeing it in a different perspective.
And I went home for the wake and the funeral.
Well,
that first night I decided to have a campfire in my parent's backyard and pull
together all of our friends because when something really bad happens,
I feel one of the most healing things we can do is share our perspective on what
did happen to speak up,
to speak our truth.
And so I have this bonfire and most of the people in attendance that night were
me and Shannon's sorority sisters.
Um,
and so we're sitting around,
we're all,
you know,
and the ages of,
let's say like 19 to 22 for the most part.
And for the first few hours we're talking about Shannon,
we're talking about who could have done this because at that point the guy who
murdered her had not been caught.
So it was just a super intense time around that.
But I noticed the evening progressed,
we stopped talking specifically about Shannon and we started talking about our
own experiences as women in regards to safety and fear and I started hearing
some of my best friends in the world.
Educated,
strong,
smart,
bold,
beautiful women.
Say things like,
you know what?
After,
after what happened to Shannon,
I don't want to take that internship at the hospital downtown Chicago cause it
just probably isn't safe to be walking to my car at night
or after.
What has happened to Shannon?
I've learned that you know this guy I'm dating,
we've been talking about moving in together and I was thinking about breaking up
with them.
I don't think he's my guy,
but I might as well just move in with him because it's probably safer to not
sleep alone at night.
Then another friend saying,
I have this whole trip planned to backpack Europe Solo,
and all of a sudden after this is occurred,
it just feels like a really radically unsafe thing to do.
This went on for hours,
hours of us,
strong,
empowered,
bold,
educated women talking about all the things we weren't going to do because
fundamentally we were afraid.
And I remember just listening that whole night and really taking it all in and
realizing the injustice,
not just the violence,
but of the fact that we were able to be who we truly are because fundamentally
we were afraid to be.
And that seems like the bigger,
the bigger injustice and the two things in that moment,
because I thought to myself,
what would Shannon be upset about?
She'd be pissed about that she'd be upset,
that we weren't taking the trips and we weren't being with the right people and
we weren't taking the jobs that we're going to fill us up.
That's what she'd be upset about.
And so that was the first time that I started to realize the power of speaking
truth,
especially in a healing situation like that.
Well,
the next day was the wake and it's one of these wakes when someone young dies.
I mean there's just huge,
right?
Just hundreds of people.
She was a very loved person and at all American athlete,
very popular woman.
And so we're waiting for hours to get to the front of the way can into pair
respects and to meet her family.
And so in these hours I had a lot of time to think about what it occurred.
And by the time we got to the front,
I had been thinking about,
well,
what are you going to say in those situations?
Like how do you speak your truth when it,
it's almost like the unspeakable has happened.
How does that work?
And so it had to kind of surrender at that moment when we got up to the front to
just be like,
all right,
well,
whatever's going to come out is going to come out and I'm just going to have to
be a piece of that,
but I'm just going to have to be real.
And the awfulness of this.
Well,
before I met her family,
I kneel in front of her casket and I just remember thinking,
this feels so unsolvable.
This feels so permanent and unfixable.
But then I also had a moment where I was like,
I don't think people who have passed in the way that she did would want us to
stay paralyzed in that.
I think that we don't have to put a,
at the end of those kinds of stories,
when those injustices happen,
but we need to put a comma and we need to keep speaking for them cause they
can't speak for themselves.
And so I get up and I meet her family.
Now,
you know when you go to college and you have these like super tight friends that
are,
they're like your family,
but you never know where they came from because you're not hanging out with
their family.
They're far away.
So I'd never met her,
her mom,
Cindy,
but I had always heard so much about her and she apparently had heard so much
about me because I introduced her.
I'm like,
hi,
I'm Aaron Weed.
I'm so sorry about what's happened.
And she just like cuts me off.
She was like,
Oh,
you're a week.
He's like,
hey man,
we got to last name.
Like we,
you gotta like just own that,
you know?
So in college I was weed,
by the way,
I'm totally running for governor someday,
governor of Colorado.
I'm come on,
get all the trustafarians I'm Pearl Street to be my campaign managers will be
awesome,
you know?
So,
uh,
so Cindy was like,
oh my God.
I was like,
oh yeah,
this is kind of weird.
Okay,
we're just having this moment and we're laughing and um,
and she goes,
she's squeezed my hand.
We had this instant connection.
She said,
me,
you know what we,
it's so crazy.
But even after the worst thing that has happened,
the losing a child,
I don't,
I don't know that there's too many more worse things that can happen in a human
existence.
She said,
you know what?
There's something worse.
And I was like,
what could possibly be worse than what has occurred?
Like this moment will,
it could possibly be worse.
She's like,
what's worse is that I'm so afraid that the world is going to forget about her.
I'm so afraid that everyone's gonna forget her name.
And I remember in that moment just being like,
wow,
just the moment of of that sinking in of that,
how we can have levels of fear and how her bigger fear in that moment was just
the forgetting of people not hearing about her anymore.
And I think a lot of us have had that fear maybe for ourselves.
If you've ever been faced with your own mortality or the mortality of a loved
one,
what do people forget?
And remember in that moment as a 22 year old woman just being like,
you know what?
That is one thing I know how to do,
cause I had a big mouth and I can make sure I can't solve violence.
I can't end murder,
but I know how to talk and I can get other people to talk and speak their truth.
And so I kind of walked away from that,
realizing the power of speaking truth transcends death.
It transcends tragedy and all of those different things.
What I ended up doing with the help of many,
many people,
a great community.
It's starting a company called girls fight back.
What we did was women's safety and self defense seminars.
We mostly went into high schools and colleges all across the world in addition
to the United States.
We also expanded into India and Pakistan and we localized the content so that it
was specific to their culture and to the safety risks that they faced.
And in addition to all that,
we were doing the radio shows and the TV shows and I read a book and a magazine
column for Cosmo girl and it was amazing.
It was just such an incredible program,
but it's some points.
There came this,
this point about 12 years in,
in that period of time I'd had two children.
A lot of things had shifted and there came this point where I realized it was no
longer my story to tell.
It felt like it was almost this old story.
Not like it wasn't significant,
but almost like I had crossed the bridge from pain to peace.
And I noticed that a lot of times in the victim world,
it doesn't matter what one is a victim of,
sometimes people can get stuck in the story.
And that prevents us from being in our truth.
And I started to give myself permission to let that story not need to be the
center of my being anymore and to just let it go and to let it dissipate.
And so as I started doing that,
it was very kind of painful because sometimes we can be identified by our
stories.
It's almost like this,
this egoic attachment that we have.
Well,
I'm,
I'm a woman that NBC calls when something bad happens and I'm there to be able
to show up and offer safety strategies and that's who I am
or is it?
And so it started to kind of slip away in the identity started to slip away.
And so I ended up selling the company because I knew that it was time for
someone else to tell that story and their version of it.
And I had a bit of a identity crisis because at that moment I'm like,
well who am I now?
You know,
if I'm not the ass kicking girl.
Um,
cause by the way,
I'm like one of the most highly trained women in the world and ask kicking.
I'm really fun at parties,
like just um,
really handy skill that you can do nothing with.
Right.
So,
uh,
so I found myself in a little bit of a crisis of sorts.
I wasn't Midlife,
but uh,
definitely a crisis.
I started thinking about what I'd learned about seeking purpose and speaking
truth and how can I show up in a new way and to both of those things.
I started working for Ted and Tedx and Tedx Boulder,
started coaching for them,
Develop Their Speaker coaching program,
also Ted x mile high.
And I was just so excited about this idea of really distilling down our truth
and to like the 10 to 18 minutes turning it into a story that can really
captivate and then affecting audiences by it.
I started doing the speaker coaching thing,
but I realized that there's so much more to it when you get somebody that's like
a ted speaker and they're brilliant and they've got these amazing ideas and
they've done these epic things and they come in.
I was thinking to myself,
I don't want to just make them shiny.
I want them to seek their truth and share that with the masses because that's
going to be so much more powerful.
So I came up with this thing called the dig,
which I'm going to share with you today.
Uh,
at least a little snippet of it because these people needed to understand their
purpose and their why and their drive behind it if they were going to really be
able to show up and communicate authentically.
But I feel like speaking truth not only affects us in the personal,
but also in the business world.
Shortly after I sold girl sway back and started working for Ted,
there was also kind of a personal churning and it was happening.
I was starting to realize that the marriage I was in was not a good marriage.
It was,
he's not a bad person,
but it was really built on some pretty inauthentic foundations and this was
rough because not only had I lost my girls fight back identity at that point,
my other identity was being a married mom of two kids and I started getting
really shaken at the idea of like I don't think I'm supposed to be here anymore.
I don't come from a family of divorce.
I actually used to hold a lot of judgment around it and I remember being in that
moment and be like,
Oh man,
this is going to be so bad,
but this is what I have to do to be real is to leave this mirrors.
It was not healthy you probably for either one of us,
so it was very painful.
But I started to go through the process of moving.
Now when I put my house on the market,
at the time we had been living in Broomfield and put my house in the market and
like how do you find a realtor?
Well apparently I find it by like the grocery carts,
you know those realtors?
Like what a bizarre place to like put an ad like where your,
where your baby's butts.
It's like all day I whatever.
It worked for me apparently.
So this guy looked friendly so I was like,
Hey,
I'll call him.
So I called him,
I think his name was John,
I forget,
but he comes over and it's like him and his wife and they're like this dynamic
duo and they got their whole system down and they're like,
okay,
what do you want to sell the house for and how many bedrooms is a head and
doesn't have a basement?
Is it finished and what's the garage like?
And so they were,
they were like had locked down.
It was tight.
Like from a business perspective,
how they showed up was like completely solid but never once did they ask why I
was selling my house.
They had no idea what was going on personally.
They were so in their heads about the facts of what was occurring and how they
could help me in that sense that they weren't really looking at the bigger
experience of what does it mean to let go of your home.
And that was okay because their jobs is so my house,
right.
Well,
they did a good job within one day my house was sold and it was sold to someone
with a cash offer.
Now a few weeks after that happened,
everything was just like done.
I'm moving to Boulder,
I'm moving forward.
Somebody asked me,
hey,
what's the name of your realtor?
Cause I want to sell my house.
And you sold quick and everything for the life from you guys.
I could not remember.
I could not remember these people's names and I still get,
I still don't know what I mean.
I called the Dude John,
because that's like statistically a good likelihood.
But I mean,
I didn't know.
And I think the reason is because there was no connection beyond just the facts
and what was coming going on in the head.
Now on the flip side,
as I was starting to move,
I was looking for movers.
There were no ads on grocery carts for that.
So I had to do a little more digging,
a little more yelping.
I found this random company and hired him and this duo of dudes were amazing and
one specifically,
his name was Frederick and he was this super charismatic guy who loved his job,
used to work in tech.
And I remember asking him like,
Hey Frederick,
you know,
to kind of doing the whole business professional meeting someone thing and you
know,
how do you do what you do and how'd you get here?
He's like,
he used to work in tech but I wanted to be a mover.
I wanted to haul stuff.
And he's like,
no,
I don't want to haul stuff.
I want to move people.
And I'm like,
Oh this is exciting,
you know?
And he probably read the look on my face and being like,
why?
And he's like,
yeah,
we're going to move you,
but I'm going to move here.
I'm like,
okay.
Like I said,
like feel the need to know cause I was like,
do you feel in me?
You know what I'm talking about,
I'm going to move you.
And I was like,
not really.
He's like,
he's like,
why are you selling your house?
And I was like,
I'm selling my house cause I'm getting divorced.
Why are you getting forced?
Wow.
Going there.
And in that moment though,
I was like,
wow,
that's so appropriate.
That is so appropriate.
Because he was being real and curious.
There was no judgment in that question.
He was just legitimately curious like,
oh you're,
you're moving cause you're getting divorced.
Why,
what happened?
So you know,
I actually told him a few sayings,
whatever.
And he's like,
all right,
it's time to move you forward.
This is not a house.
This is your life.
And we're moving,
you know,
like he was giving me like this sermon in my kitchen and um,
and I started realizing,
oh my gosh,
this is a mover.
His only job is to move my stuff and get his why he's authentic meaning for what
he does is that he wants to move people.
He wants to just like take them from this phase and get them into the next phase
of their life.
He was able to see that this wasn't about a moving truck and strong muscles.
This was about helping people make hard transitions.
And because he did that two weeks later when somebody asks me for a
recommendation on a mover,
I'm like,
oh my God,
you had to call Frederick.
Here's his cell phone number.
He just texted the other day.
So I feel like we can learn a lot in business in addition to our personal lives,
if we're willing to show up more than just in our head and our thoughts and just
the transactions we're actually able to get with each other and connect on the
heart level and the core level of like,
what do you want?
How can we get you where you want to go?
We can feel that.
And so that's what I want to share with you guys say and actually give you the
experience of how to do that.
And where we're going to do that is this exercise as a part of the dig.
I call it head hardcore.
And the difference between a mysterious John,
the realtor and awesome Fredericton mover,
was that Frederick showed up from all three places.
He was willing to connect with me on the facts.
He was willing to connect with me on the feelings.
And he was willing to connect with me on the desires
and he was willing to hold all of it and I think we can all show up in this way.
This is how we be authentic is communicating the facts.
Yes and the feelings.
Yes and the desires.
Yes,
but we do it not just from a place of transparency but from authenticity.
Now I gave a Tedx boulder talk just this past fall and it was on that topic.
What's the difference between being transparent and being authentic?
My opinion is that it's showing up in all three of these from the head,
the heart and the core.
Have you ever met somebody who is just one of these people that just spouts off
anything in a moment and they're like super proud of how authentic they are even
when they're hurting people and like making people cry?
I actually don't think that's authentic.
That's wounded transparency and those are totally different things.
Just because you have no filter doesn't make you a real person.
It makes you a wounded person who's not doing the work to find out what's really
true.
Because the reality about authenticity is that if we go and communicate about
what we feel about something from the head,
the heart and the core,
it usually ends in a very soft place.
It doesn't usually end in like poison as vitriol.
Okay.
Our truth,
I believe for most people is a kind truth.
It is a peaceful truth.
It is one who wants best for self but best for others.
So today what I want to do is take you through the head hardcore exercise.
This is something that I developed as I started working with these Ted people
from all over the world who are trying to show up like the realtor.
But really they had to show up like the mover.
They were trying to show up and just talk about their new scientific innovation
and they just wanted to stay here with the needed to drop down here.
But what they felt about it and what they believe for it,
what they desired for it.
And that is what really started my new company because that was the thing that
was working.
So people fly over all over the world to work with me on their ted talks.
But what they're really getting is a better self understanding about what their
truth is and permission to actually share that with people.
And guess what?
On the other side of that,
people are so excited because now you have given them permission to show up in
that way too.
And that's the ripple I'm talking about.
So let's talk about the head,
the heart and the core.
Um,
the head is feeling,
or I'm sorry,
the head,
his thoughts.
It is things that we think it is things that are undisputably true.
Things like your age.
If you have a dog where you're from,
where you went to college,
these are our head facts.
They are things that are indisputable.
The next part is the heart.
These are feelings.
This is what's true for you emotionally in that moment.
The thing about being in the heart is that it's changing constantly.
What's true for you emotionally 10 minutes ago could be true for,
could be totally different than what's true for you 10 minutes from now.
So part of the trick about being in the heart and why so much of our culture
doesn't stay here or go here even is because it requires presence.
It requires us to actually stop
and breathe and feel for a second to even know what's happening there.
So we have a lot of unconsciousness happening in our culture because we're just
not dialed into that.
And then finally the core is I desire,
it's what we want now,
especially women.
We're kind of trained to to keep that under wraps a bit like no one wants to
hear a woman walking around and tell them,
I want you to talk about what you desire is what she wants in the world.
She sounds demanding.
Well guess what?
When we do this part of the exercise,
but you're probably going to notice in the room is when you get a room full of
people who are showing up and talking about what they want.
There's this energy of like,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
like because what you want is probably very similar to what other people want
and like can we all please just give each other permission to save what we want?
It's,
it's so freeing for everyone.
And even if in relationships,
even,
have you ever been in a relationship with somebody where they're like mad at you
and you can't figure out why and they won't tell you what they want,
but you're trying to figure it out.
I mean like that is a losing battle for everyone.
But if they just say it,
even if it means the relationship is over,
it's such a thief because you're finally in the truth of it.
So what I'd love to do is just not just explain this,
but actually give you guys an experience of what does it mean to be in the head,
heart and core.
And like I said,
I developed this for Ted speakers because this is,
this is the ingredient for any of any of you who do public speaking.
This is how you speak.
You find the balance of,
I think I feel,
and I want,
if you can find a balance of those three things and for every speech is
different depending on the intention of the outcome.
But if you can find that balance,
that's how people are going to get the most full authentic expression of you.
And on the other side of that is where the connection occurs.
So it happens in one to one situations,
one to some settings.
If you're leading a team or one to many,
like giving a talk or even giving a Webinar.
So head,
heart core,
it's like a recipe.
So I was wondering if I could get maybe three brave volunteers to come up here
and help me out with an exercise.
It's going to require speaking from the head,
heart,
and core.
Yeah,
get rid of [inaudible].
All right.
Okay.
[inaudible] 50 guys over here.
Okay,
so first of all,
thank you guys so much for showing up for this.
It can be kind of a brave and scary thing to intentionally speak your truth.
And what I want to do before we begin is almost put a little bubble around this
room,
you know,
for all of you up there,
for all of you down here,
for all of us on stage,
I'm just kind of imagine we have a bubble of safety for a moment.
I know even before I came onstage,
your first session was some people were sharing some really amazing powerful
stories.
And so let's,
let's kind of like reclaimed that energy of safety because we got to have safety
to show up and speak our truth.
So
this exercise,
what we're going to do is we're going to simply introduce ourselves.
So I'm going to model it.
Then our three friends up here are each going to do there,
um,
custom piece of what I've modeled and introduced themselves.
And then we're going to have you guys pair up and you guys were wanting to do
this with a partner.
So I want you to experience it as well as learning.
So what we're going to do basically is introduce ourselves three times first
from the head,
then from the heart,
then from the core.
Now you might be thinking,
well that's a bit repetitive and it's actually not.
Because introducing ourselves from these three places is a totally different
experience.
And what I'd like for you to notice as we're doing this exercise is how it is in
your body and what comes out of your mouth.
There's only one rule in all this outside of just confidentiality and safety.
Can we all agree to that?
Okay,
so outside of that,
the only rule is that you can't rehearse while other people are talking.
And people always laugh at that because it's true because that's what we're all
doing.
Even the most present
amazing person,
we're all rehearsing.
Some of us are better at it than others,
so it's just less office.
But we're all doing it all the time.
Now let's think about it for a moment.
What are the repercussions of the whole world where everyone is rehearsing what
other people are talking?
We're not listening,
but even worse on the other side of that,
we're not connecting that thing that's like a survival deal that can actually
increase our lifespan.
We're not getting that.
And we have a very lonely separate world right now despite being how connected
we are.
So we need to start with being present.
And in order to do that,
we need to trust that if we show up presently from the head harder core,
whatever's going to come out is perfect and it's probably going to be 10 times
better than what you rehearsed.
And I've seen this firsthand.
Okay.
So while we're all not rehearsing,
um,
I'm going to kick this off now.
Can I have a timer as someone good with the phone and,
okay,
cool.
Jess.
Sometimes I try to do it and I screw up the whole thing.
All right.
I get like so into it and then okay,
can you do like 60 seconds?
So there is a time component.
The reason is I'm a hyper distiller.
I don't think we need a ton of time and space to do some of the things we think
that we need.
Things like getting to your truth.
People like Whoa,
that sounds heavy and long.
Not really want to know how I know this.
Cause I have a five year old.
She gets to our truth really fast right now.
She's in a phase where she's not wearing shoes.
Everybody knows about it.
It's very clear.
I'm not going to ask you today mom.
Okay.
All right.
She's very clear that speaking from the core,
I will not wear shoes,
but it doesn't take a long time to get to your truth.
Well,
it does take a long time just to filter out all of this stuff.
Do we have that stopped us from having permission for ourselves to speak our
truth.
That's a totally different thing that we all have as adults,
but this process will help us take us through.
So with one minute on the clock,
I'm going to introduce myself from my head.
Facts only,
completely unrehearsed,
which you're probably gonna notice within yourself and maybe watching other
people is that some of us are really good in the head.
Some of us are really good in the heart.
Some of us are really good in the core.
Most of us are not good at all three or I shouldn't say not good.
It's just not comfortable.
It's not like your go to and that's okay.
I'm not here to teach you how to be better at it.
I'm just here to teach you how to bring consciousness to when you're in which
space.
Okay.
For better.
For worse.
So one minute.
All right.
Just let's do this thing.
Okay.
Facts only if I say a feeling you kind of all go and
totally non abrasive.
Alright,
so facts only.
Um,
my name is Aaron Weed.
My middle name is Underwood.
I was made fun of a lot for my weird name through growing up.
Graduation ceremonies were kind of the,
the biggest part.
Aaron Underwood weed and everyone would laugh.
I don't think it's that funny,
but whatever.
Um,
I am from Chicago.
I lived in New York after that.
Have started a few companies.
I have two children,
ages eight and five.
We live in boulder.
Just moved last week.
Thought I would make it more interesting and adopt a puppy this weekend.
So far that's proven to be intellectually factually true.
It's more interesting.
Um,
I am learning to play the Ukulele.
Okay.
Thank you.
So there are my facts.
you'll also notice I kept my head on my my hand and had a little time.
You're probably wondering why I was doing that.
Here's why this exercise is about teaching conscious awareness about when you're
in your head,
your heart and your core.
The reason I'm doing that is so that you can have the power to shift out of your
head harder core and into a different place in your,
in your communications.
So for this exercise we're all gonna put our hands where we're speaking from so
that we could start learning where we are.
It makes sense.
It's like kinesthetic screen.
Okay,
cool.
So hand on your head.
One minute backs only about who you are.
Hi,
I'm Lisa
to Denver,
recently from New York and from who lives in New York from Seattle.
So that's where I originally come from and I got engaged in October and we have
a small dog.
His name is Connor.
Small dogs.
Name is Gabby.
Hmm.
We call him our son a junior senator Sunday.
My fiance,
Connor just got a job and I and switching teams payments and I am going to take
30 days off in between to wreak.
How much time do I have?
I do a little bit with,
okay.
Hi,
my name is Leslie Pace.
I am a Colorado native.
However,
I wasn't wearing Oklahoma,
moved here when I was six.
Um,
grew up in a rural Colorado.
and would you change the high school that way?
Anybody is familiar?
Um,
then I graduated from there and [inaudible] Howard University in Washington DC
where I studied computer information systems,
minor in information assurance and I also learned how to jab it in my men very
well,
easy.
And came back home.
I was managing restaurants in DC and my dad said,
we pay you to go manage restaurants.
I said,
no.
And I came home and I started working at a startup called zen planner,
any Middleton and they do information systems,
fitness businesses and I actually,
it was there.
Right.
My name is Paige Jessica [inaudible] and my name never fit on scantrons growing
up,
uh,
I'm the Admin in g tech.
I've been at Google for eight years.
I started out as a TVC and became an Mtu 2011.
I just recently in August moves,
uh,
Irving,
California to Colorado and it,
aside from a one year stint in Germany,
it's the only time I've lived outside of California,
but I'm really excited that I left.
Uh,
I got my degree in German and international relations.
I live with my boyfriend,
Noah and our two dogs.
Budget and Bogart.
Uh,
I love to,
but you can.
Yep.
Yeah,
I am outside a lot
next week and,
okay,
so now it's your turn.
I'd love for you to find a partner and one minute for each of you.
I'll tell you when the minute's up.
So remember hand on the head.
Facts only ready and break.
30 seconds.
Okay.
So
what did you all notice about speaking from the head?
Hollered out or it's hard to not say things you're like,
yeah.
What else do you learn?
You ran out of facts.
Okay.
It's like,
I gotta get going.
We've got a headboard
right here,
right?
It's hard to disconnect emotion.
Okay.
Okay,
great.
Like,
I'm a totally lame person.
What a tough discovery at a workshop,
you know?
Um,
well the great thing about head like this,
this is by no means the,
the punchline is not like don't stay in your head,
don't like go to your head.
Like that's not the punchline.
The punchline is don't live in your head.
Okay.
And that's what a lot of our culture dies is we live in our head like networking
events.
Great example.
You go to a networking event,
what are the two questions people ask you?
What you do,
where are you from and what do you do right over and over and over again.
And it's what it leads to is just this culture of disconnection because that's
like where we're starting now.
I don't have a problem with starting there.
If you use it as a jumping off point to go somewhere else because it can be
socially awkward just to walk up to someone and be like,
what are you passionate?
You know,
like sometimes got to lie
no a little bit.
But if we just let it go there,
what are the things I notice about like the where are you from?
What do you do thing,
especially the,
where are you from?
Like you'd be like,
oh,
I'll be like,
I'm from Chicago.
And then the person I was meant to like,
oh,
I have a cousin who was from Wilmette,
which is outside of Chicago.
Oh really?
Where'd she go to school?
And Oh really?
She wants a lawyer all,
I have a friend who was a loyal and I'm like,
where is this going?
We're now talking about two people that neither one of us really know at this
point.
Anyway,
not authentic.
Very,
very transparent.
Okay,
so we want to go for the authenticity,
the head,
the heart and the court as a blend.
But another one of the reasons head is important is because it gives context.
Oh,
week where that,
where's that person from?
Now we can place them.
There's something about having context that allows you to trust someone.
Like if I would've just stepped up here and started talking about stuff and
Alison had introduced me and you had no context of like what my deal was,
what my background was,
you'd be thinking,
why the heck is this woman here right now?
And like why am I listening to her?
Like I don't,
I don't understand.
So head is is powerful and important as long as we don't stay there forever.
Okay,
so now let's move on to the second part.
The heart.
Now for this part of the exercise,
I'm going to give you two minutes.
The reason is
two minutes of feelings everybody.
That's what you got today.
So the reason I make this a little bit longer is because I like to create some
time and space for you to even figure this stuff out before you start talking.
So many times in our culture,
we just talk way too soon.
We just started saying all this crazy stuff that is not true,
not authentic,
maybe not even transparent,
just because we are conditioned to fill the space.
So in your personal relationships,
in business,
doesn't matter.
I encourage you all to take a minute,
take a day,
take a week,
take what you need to figure out what is the authentic emotion.
So within this exercise,
I'd love for you all to start out.
We're all have our hand on our heart and start off and just
taking a breath.
Close your eyes if you need to just drop in with yourself.
What if we did this like eight times a day?
Would that be an interesting life?
We wouldn't be so lame anymore because it actually kind of see well I'm like a
complex individual.
I've got range,
you know,
and it's true.
So we need to like drop down and sink in to even figure it.
Figure out what that is.
Okay.
So I'll model it for you.
Give it two minutes.
All right.
Okay.
What am I feeling?
So I'm in this space right now where I'm feeling total joy and connection
because of this puppy that I adopted.
I have not had a dog for like years cause my pug died a few years ago and I've
always wanted this French bulldog,
like one a French bulldog.
But I didn't want to do a breeder cause I have this like ethical thing around
it.
I was like,
I want to adopt a French bulldog,
like,
and they just,
it doesn't happen very often.
And then she came through Petfinder,
which I would get obsessive,
Lee.
And she showed up and she was given up and discarded by a breeder because she
has this epic underbite
like out of control,
like cheap hanging out of mouth,
like she's 11 pounds.
And I just remember feeling in that moment like,
oh my God,
that's my dog.
Like,
and I just moved a week ago and this is terrible timing and awful,
but like something in my heart,
just like it was exploding for this little creature.
And so we rescued her on Sunday and ever since then,
and I'm like,
even total puppy craziness,
but it's just like something about her.
It's like re awakened what it means to connect what it means to care for people,
what it means to,
um,
to be straight forward about what you need.
Like,
like,
don't eat my couch.
Hmm.
Do that crap there.
You know,
but just a button,
a loving sort of way just to show up in that way.
And so I've really been basking in that.
And,
uh,
yesterday my kids met her for the first time and it was just like,
I'm still kind of like riding it.
Um,
and it's for me kind of a welcome respite just with so much that's going on in
the world right now.
I actually kind of came out of like a month of just,
just not dumps per se,
but just feeling like just the world was disconnected from each other,
you know,
and uh,
it just kinda felt dark and a little hopeless after the school shooting and
missing school shooting like really kind of rocked me to my core because I,
I used to get the calls,
that sort of thing would happen.
And now I have two kids that are in elementary school and it's just real in a
whole different way.
And so
by the time,
so when the time ends,
like you finish your thought because otherwise it's just a Brompton feels weird
for everybody.
So really,
um,
in closing what I've been feeling into,
it's just like the paradox of what it is to be alive,
of like holding the light and the dark in the very same moment and the joy and
the pain in the very same moment and just trying to become
more,
more skillful with just allowing it all to be true.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
good breath.
The whole room can take a breath too.
Cause when you're hearing other people share,
it can be heavy on,
on you as well.
This one's telling me that this is a self soothing
bowler
bourbon holder,
Neha,
last year started and pretty much from day one as in a situation that wasn't
good for me.
Um,
it's a complex thing and it's many reasons but ultimately it wasn't a good team
fit.
But I'm not,
not the same amount of clutter because there's plenty of things that we have up
on with.
But I want to succeed.
And so I,
I spent so much of my energy and my time talking about people who
were breaking you down.
So much of that spend doing that at home,
in Van Pool.
Just anyone that would listen.
And to the point that I just got tired of having,
having that be my story every day.
And so
putting a good amount of work and I want to the courage to say this isn't my
place anymore and I,
I want to succeed and I think I can succeed,
but it can't be on this team and I'm switching teams.
And since that does,
like it all got approved and everything's settled down and I have a few weeks
left in my pain and it is amazing how when I know that the consequences of the
day to day interactions aren't going to affect me anymore.
How much for your I am on how,
how empowered him to actually do my job.
I've done more of job in the past month effectively and well then I think I did
in the three months prior just because I'm finally free.
And so it just then decided like,
wow,
I've got,
when I'm in a space where I feel really safe and really awesome.
Yeah.
Oh,
and I'm finished.
How much work did I do there?
I just moved out of my parents' house so I feel really free.
I'm really excited about it.
Even,
you know,
10 to 61 square feet to me,
really happy about it and I definitely did factor into my neighbor's car.
I feel nervous.
I felt very responsible because I wrote him a note to smell store while I was in
my pj's.
Hi.
I feel very optimistic and my brother is graduating high school soon on the arm.
He's thought to go to college architecture.
Um,
I'm scared he has epilepsy that is triggered by sleep deprivation and you know,
you're in college.
How are you doing this day and all night?
And uh,
I was like morality,
you know,
Kendra can you alcohol,
you can be out here and say that Blake pulling all nighters.
It's not a thing that you can do like everybody up,
he's going to be balanced in the house.
Nervous,
but I'm excited.
Um
Hm.
Yeah.
MMM.
She is my little brother.
He's six.
Five.
Okay.
Teach.
Yes.
Started growing dreadlocks.
Don't like them.
And that is what matters.
Took
him to see Kendrick Lamar there his 18th birthday.
And he was so excited and he said
all of a sudden,
and he is an old man and a young man.
You were younger,
I would say,
hey,
let's go get ice cream.
You'd be like,
I already have my pajamas on.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I feel lots of feelings
all the time.
Actually.
Three feeling person,
wear glasses on you're feeling,
it's like go out
like watching commercial.
It's just when you say something Nice I get teary and it's really annoying trait
that I have,
but I'm kind of learning to embrace it.
I'm 31 years old and I feel like your thirties are about embracing who you are
and uh,
and acknowledging and loving yourself for who you are.
I spent,
I am
right as I was actually able to watch game of Thrones,
I just like,
but I feel like spent a lot of the,
uh,
the last couple of years,
kind of working through this part of who I am and that being okay.
And it also coexisting with other parts of who I am and like the smart parts in
the professional parts hardhearted parts.
And,
uh,
and also just growing up,
I feel like I'm in a growing up kind of phase.
I recently kind of separated from my dad and that was a really don't know why
I'm sharing but really hard a year,
but also really about me and it being okay to be unique and that you don't,
you don't need everyone else's approval around you to be you and to love you for
you.
So yeah.
That's good.
[inaudible] Hey,
I'm hot to you guys.
I just want to just make a note because like I can feel your self consciousness
in it.
Like how easy is it?
Is it to hear her like it's so easy to,
to just be with you in the authenticity of it and like what if we as women,
we could let of any judgment if we show up in that emotional way.
Like it's just so easy to hear you,
so thank you.
So,
um,
at this point we can't go back to our partners two minutes for each.
Did you notice about
the difference between the head and the heart outside of the visual difference
of the room.
Okay,
interesting.
Okay.
What else?
Yeah,
yeah.
It was uncomfortable.
They just aren't typically things that would come out in a first meeting with
being censored and like feeling sort of that polite.
Those highlights,
social boundaries.
You wouldn't off put those things on.
Somebody told her offloading actually kind of,
it's the opposite I think.
It's
like you don't know anything about me and everybody is like [inaudible] my
therapist [inaudible]
okay.
Some of the things I said was they felt but never set up that very cool.
Interesting.
Did anyone who tends to be more of a head person because just because we're
mostly women here,
it doesn't mean we're all heart people.
You know,
there's,
there's women who are just more head people too.
So it was there anybody who is more of a head person,
you've almost noticed yourself like analyzing the feeling like I think that I
feel this and you can almost like,
and you can usually tell when you're doing the exercise,
when someone's like,
I had person thinking about their feelings when it's just like there's no body
match up,
you know,
so it can come off as being a little incongruent.
So,
so had people have to be careful of that.
Um,
so that people,
that people don't distrust them because it's not matching up,
if you know what I mean.
So,
so heart is really important.
Like there's a lot of connection because at the end of the day,
we're all human beings and that's the thing we have in common and this is where
we can really connect.
But on the flip side,
just as if we,
if we show up at our head all the time and there's a lack of connection if we
just showed up and were just like bleeding all over the floor,
um,
with our feelings,
98% of the time,
after a while,
people are gonna start avoiding you because that's exhausting.
I work with a lot of activists that are trying to make big change in the world
and a lot of these activists are trying to make this change because something
bad happened and it woke us up to something a better way.
And it's just kind of this natural thing to just go into the,
and this happened and this happened to me and this was awful.
And this person died and bled,
you know,
like it's all bad.
Like as someone who talks about rape and murder for 12 years,
it's,
and we need to be able to talk about it from the head and we need to be able to
talk about it from the core to and balance it out.
Otherwise people get emotionally exhausted and you don't,
you don't connect that either.
So everything is about balance.
So that's the heart.
The final piece of this and then we're going to tie up is the court,
we're going to shift back to one minute for this.
You might not even need all that time and you don't have to use it on.
Speaking from the cork tends to be very short,
very to the point.
My daughter,
I don't want to wear shoes very clear.
It doesn't necessarily need to make sense.
So let's just,
you know,
release ourselves from having to,
for that to happen.
It can just be what you want in that moment.
I want this,
I want that.
And so I find that a good prompts when we do the core,
and you might want to do this with your partners,
just start off with what do you want.
In some ways it can sound abrasive,
but in other ways it can sound totally free.
Really.
Like really I can answer that question like anyway,
want to,
okay,
here's what I bought.
You know,
so have some fun with this.
Notice what comes up.
I also notice when we speak from the core,
sometimes it can seem really random.
Like I want world peace.
I don't want to sleep later.
You know,
like it's
seemingly unrelated,
but maybe I've,
everyone slept later,
I don't know.
So just whatever we're remember,
we're not rehearsing still.
So just what everyone's come out comes out.
So this time we're just gonna hold her belly.
This is kind of the place where we manifest things.
So again,
take a good deep breath.
What do you want?
And especially by the way,
as leaders,
we need to tell people what we want.
If we want to lead people somewhere,
Martin Luther King Jr like if he gave speeches and he didn't tell people that he
had a dream,
like do you think it would have been as effective?
We wanted to get on board with that dream.
He took us somewhere.
So we need to do that as leaders in our relationships,
in our teams and in the world.
Okay,
I want,
uh,
I want to potty train my dog
cause I think it will make my life better.
I want,
um,
in this sense and more work sense,
I want people to show up more authentically.
I have the luxury of doing this for a living,
of getting people to the most authentic selves and helping them communicate.
And I see what's on the other side of that.
And it's that thing that like,
you know,
that maybe not everybody knows.
And it's so frustrating because you want everyone to know it because life is so
much better when they do that.
And so that's Kinda how I feel.
And so opportunities like this are so exciting to me so that hopefully you can
take the tool and run with it.
Um,
I want to figure out the,
um,
the violence problem in our world,
the,
and maybe even more than the violence,
like the anger and the disconnection that's behind all of that.
I want to get to the root of things and I think back up here,
but I think one of the reasons we feel so disconnected because we're all
conditioned to be inauthentic.
So I want us to show up in a different way than we maybe have been.
Cause there's really a spectrum time.
There's really a spectrum and um,
I think we can choose in every moment to show it more authentically and the in
the world would be better for it.
All right.
That's my minute.
What do you want?
I want to utilize my body to,
it's grace and Cassidy.
Um,
mostly anything physically because I just think that each of us are given the
gift of the mobility that we have and I want to be as fit and as strong as
possible.
And I want to share that gift,
a bottling mobility with other people because I think that a lot of times that's
I should work out,
work out and not like fucking get to go move my body until it sweats and wants
to like come up to the floor.
That's how I feel about it and I want to share that.
And I think it sends a lot from,
I've had four knee surgeries,
so I know what it's like to not have the ability,
not be able to use your body.
And it's not a vanity thing,
it's a feeling.
I think that I feel better about every other part of my life when I feel strong.
And I think everybody should feel strong because everybody can feel strong.
Okay,
that's awesome.
[inaudible]
all right.
I want to travel the world and speak to the masses and teach yoga everywhere and
all the big home to be a bunch of people.
And I want to get more degrees and more books.
I want to speak more languages and
I want to build better products.
I want to
be more Mac and cheese.
[inaudible] is Colorado.
USA to
buy a house.
I want to build generational wealth for future generations.
I want to own the tea company.
I want to become a restaurant too.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
I want to feel build in my career.
I want to be strong.
I want to be able to control the emotional part of me while still feeling it.
I want to have more time to read.
I want to write a book someday.
I want to go on vacation.
I want to hike more.
I want to have time.
I want to spend more time with my mom.
I want to spend more time.
Lots of people.
I want to have a sense of purpose.
I want coffee.
I want to stop now.
[inaudible]
like we're doing in this session.
So sorry.
Your Gusto into this partner up.
You got one minute.
What do you want?
So what did you notice about speaking from the court?
Powerful.
Yeah,
it's what?
Energizing.
You can feel it in the room right now.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Speaking from the court really allowed,
it allows people to follow us,
allows people to connect with us.
So as you can see from this exercise,
when we show up and speak from those three different places,
there are so distinctly different get,
they're all distinctly you.
And when you show up and you'll bring all of those things,
people can get the most authentic experience of you and you can feel the most
authentically expressed.
So the final thing I want to leave you with is just a quick little story.
Something that I do with these big Ted speakers,
right?
That after we go through this process and we write their talk,
they're always like,
okay,
well I'm gonna go give this talk.
Like any other final pieces of advice.
I'm like,
yes,
my piece of advice is for you to break a coconut.
They're like,
that is like,
like,
what am I paying you for?
Like what's happening?
And I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
So here's the deal.
So I'm in the Hindu religion.
They have the ceremony called bricking a coconut,
and it's something that you do when there is something in your space that's
preventing you from like being the human that the God's intended you to be.
So it's like your ego interfering,
fearing like either you're playing yourself down,
you're playing yourself up,
doesn't matter,
but like something's blocking it in the way.
And the question becomes what do you need to let go of?
And so in the Hindu religion,
they like approach the community.
Whoever in the community is being blocked by this thing that's preventing them
from being the awesome person that they are.
And they say,
you need to break a coconut and imagine what is that thing that you can abuse
spiritually into that coconut that you need to let go of to get out of the way
and become the person that you were supposed to be for the sake of the gods.
And so they smashed a coconut.
This person does and releases the thing that they need to get out of the way.
Maybe it's fear of money,
fear of success,
fear of being seen.
Fear of failing.
It's usually a fear of some kind,
but smashing that coconut and in that process,
smashing that thing that's preventing us from showing up as our authentic self.
And then the milk splatters everywhere.
And it's the most freeing thing.
I actually do this with clients.
Like we actually go to Boulder Creek and smash coconuts and it's in front of the
police station.
So I'm just waiting for the day that they're like,
just don't even really know how to start.
But are you breaking coconuts in nature?
But when the milk splatters,
it's amazing.
And then you pick up the pieces though of the coconut and you definitely throw
them into water.
Um,
in our case we use the Boulder Creek and the reason that you start them into
water is it's supposed to be a grateful letting go because that thing that came
into your space to prevent you from being who you truly were,
it was a gift.
It protected you.
It's some point in your life that kept you safe and now it's not needed.
And so you smashed the coconut to let it go.
But you think it on its way up.
And so my final thing I wanted to leave you today with,
it's just a question,
what do you need to let go of to be that woman or to be that man that you were
meant to be?
Let it go.
Break a coconut if you need to.
Whole foods carries them.
Get the brown ones,
shatter it,
throw the pieces of white and thank it for protecting you,
but be ready for a new layer of self to emerge.
I want to thank you all so much for having me here on International Women's Day.
It's been an absolute honor
and [inaudible]
same day,
and if anybody wanted to stay in touch,
I am local here.
My Office is right downtown boulder.
My handle is at Aaron.
We'd pretty much across the board for,
you're on social media.
I would love to stay in touch.
So thank you all so much.
[inaudible].